the Joe Rogan experience I got some
photos at Wolf's did you see those
wolves out there I saw that wolf paw
tattoo on my side do you really yeah how
much do you regret that a lot or really
a lot for those cat paws and I'm like
yeah whatever that's a weird one the dog
popped a two that's a common weird one
yeah is it yeah yeah yeah it's like
barbed wire oh yeah I love it I love a
good barbed wire side - you got any
barbed wire no I've got two sleeves
though yeah yeah these both these arms
are sleeve yeah but it's all traditional
well it's not really traditional
Japanese stuff but it's like Japanese
new style American stuff yeah no paws no
pies not that I wouldn't have got one
I'm not getting it at at tilted I was
like 25 I didn't get sleeved till I was
in my 30s yeah because I would have made
some [ __ ] choice so that should be a xxx
decision oh god I see these kids today
they're [ __ ] 18 they got face tattoos
like bro yeah slow down it's such a fun
decision to make for your whole life
like post Malone that kids talented as
[ __ ] really talented
yeah but always tired you tattooed
always tired on your face I every time I
see a picture of him I get angry I spend
I don't spend a ton of time in hair and
makeup but any time I have something
there's at least a little hair and
makeup and I'm looking at this guy and
I'm like why can't we just be that like
well I think what he's doing and what a
lot of people are doing is that they're
like going way overboard to not give a
[ __ ] just scribbling on their face oh
yeah did you see the lizzo thing from
the Lakers game you know what you did
you feel that rule I've never been here
for earthquake oh we're do we're due for
a big Wow that's why everyone keeps
saying
[Applause]